[Música]
buenos días en el 2014 me invitaron a
participar de un hackathon para muchos
de los que estamos hoy aquí la primera
pregunta que se nos puede venir a la
cabeza es que es un hackathon un
hackathon es una maratón de programación
donde en menos de 30 horas tenemos que
resolver un problema o un reto que se
nos pone ese día el caso de nosotros 50
personas tomamos la decisión de
transformar nuestras vidas en el
jaquetón y resolver el problema del
transporte público o el empleo en el
caso de mi equipo tomamos la decisión de
crear una solución de pago digital para
el transporte público lo que sin saber
nos iba a cambiar nuestra vida por
completo esto nos permitió entender el
nivel que tenía la tecnología para
cambiar la vida de miles de personas en
nuestro país y alrededor del mundo
a la vez esta iniciativa me permitió
aprender de programación de mapas que
fue una gran oportunidad para
involucrarme con una de las comunidades
a las que más le agradezco me uní a lo
que dejé pura vida técnicamente le dejé
es la comunidad de google developers
pero para los que pertenecemos a ella
sabemos que es mucho más que eso para mí
son mi familia y por cierto una familia
bastante grande somos más de 100 mil
developers alrededor del mundo en 139
países y 960 comunidades de
desarrolladores un poco grande en costa
rica
somos los google developers que nos
encargamos en costa rica de evangelizar
sobre las principales tecnologías de
google a través de charlas eventos code
lapse talleres inclusive a gatos y
además son una familia que me ha
permitido aprender muchísimo ya que
hemos organizado eventos como el google
extended que es una réplica del
entrenamiento que se hace en sillicon
valley donde se ven todas las
actualizaciones y novedades de las
tecnologías de google o por ejemplo el
de fest que es un festival de
desarrolladores alrededor del mundo
donde el año pasado tuvimos la
oportunidad de hacer historia en costa
rica y que participaron más de 500
personas durante dos días con dos
invitados especiales de colombia y
méjico y además son la familia con la
que me inicié en mi carrera en
inteligencia artificial
con proyectos como casi un asistente
virtual que junto a desarrolladores de
chile méxico y costa rica
buscamos darle a personas la capacidad
de encontrar empleo digno y en base al
salario mínimo gracias a ellos tuvimos
la oportunidad de participar en las
instalaciones de facebook para compartir
con más de 100 personas alrededor del
mundo
oab a la asistente virtual de la empresa
nacional florida ice and fun company que
les permite gracias a un equipo
multidisciplinario de personas como
abogados
científicos matemáticos permitirles que
puedan generar documentos relacionados
al mercado de ventas en cuestión de
minutos una tarea que antes le podía
tomar inclusive semanas otro de los
ejemplos es ir ya la asistente virtual
que entrenamos para que pudiera ayudar a
emprendedores startups y pymes en costa
rica méxico y colombia- en el paso a
paso de cómo ustedes pueden registrar su
empresa seguridad social impuestos o
inclusive cómo encontrar financiamiento
en el país pero definitivamente es una
esta nueva generación de asistentes
virtuales traen una funcionalidad que lo
cambiará todo por completo y es la voz
por eso en este momento tomamos la
decisión de hacer una demostración en
vivo sobre cómo nuestro asistente
virtual puede conversar con nosotros
voy a buscar la última versión de
emprender con ir ya
diría que tengo que saber sobre la
reforma fiscal
leo la verdad estoy un poco nerviosa de
estar en el td x una vida joven en 2019
no sé si pueda hacerlo
diría acuérdese que usted es una máquina
cierto leo voy a presentarme mucho gusto
soy iria la asistente virtual para
emprendedores y pymes uno de los cambios
más relevantes que debes conocer sobre
la ley de fortalecimiento de las
finanzas públicas en costa rica conocida
como el plan fiscal es el
establecimiento del impuesto al valor
agregado iva que sustituye al de ventas
y amplía los servicios en los que se
debe cobrar este tributo técnica todos
preguntarles
que es el iva
el iva es el impuesto al valor agregado
que sustituye al actual impuesto general
sobre las ventas por lo que graba todas
las ventas de bienes y la prestación de
servicios bueno por último iría
cuando empieza a regir la reforma
todo lo relativo a iva y renta en costa
rica empieza a regir a partir del
primero de julio de este año y vos leo
ya estás preparado una pregunta bastante
difícil pero bueno como pudimos ver a
través del procesamiento del lenguaje
natural logramos identificar las
intenciones que tienen los usuarios y en
base a esto tablet posibles respuestas
esta es una tecnología que lo está
cambia que lo está cambiando todo y por
lo cual nosotros hoy los invitamos a que
sean parte de esta revolución la
inteligencia artificial puede cambiar no
sólo la vida mía sino la de ustedes la
de un país la de una economía y la del
mundo en general como por ejemplo a
nosotros nos dio la oportunidad de
participar en la conferencia anual de
developers en sillicon valley donde
fuimos a entrenarnos sobre todas las
novedades y últimas actualizaciones
sobre inteligencia artificial para
traerlo al país esto nos ha permitido a
ir a países como méxico colombia
argentina eeuu aprendiendo sobre las
principales técnicas y últimas novedades
que tiene la inteligencia artificial
pero bueno mucho se nos habla sobre la
capacidad que tiene la inteligencia
artificial de destruir empleos pero muy
pocas veces se nos habla sobre la
capacidad que tiene la inteligencia
artificial de transformar nuestras vidas
y es por esto que hoy teníamos la misión
de cambiar esto y hacer algo
completamente diferente en este momento
les anunciamos que nuestra columna del
planeta chat bot pueden encontrar como
cada uno de ustedes pueden generar su
próximo asistente virtual ya sea para su
ong para su emprendimiento para su pyme
o inclusive si usted es un banco a
través de la tecnología de axxion son
google usted va a poder desarrollar una
vez para múltiples dispositivos una vez
que usted desarrolla está disponible
para el auto está disponible para el
reloj teléfonos casas inteligentes
speakers y muchos otros dispositivos
nunca antes en la historia de la
humanidad había sido tan accesible
formar parte de esta revolución
bienvenidos a la futuro de la
computación conversacional muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]